[Auto-generated transcript. Edits may have been applied for clarity.]
דרך. אגב, הכנתם שאלות כי לא קיבלתי במייל פרטי.
בעיות? אוקיי.
אוקיי, כמו שאמרתי בשיעור הקודם ישירות לנקודה של חזרה.
צריכים להסתכל מבחנים או משהו, לעבוד על נושאים מסוימים.
ככה היא שאלה ככה. או.
קיי. אתם אולי רוצים לעיין ברשימת הנושאים כדי לענות לי, לא משנה על מה נעשה חזרה.
ככה פשוט. בדרך כלל אני יודע שסטודנטים מעוניינים וזה השיעור האחרון.
אוקיי, אז אני אחזור על רשימת הנושאים. אוקיי, בסדר, תראו אם אם לא אז אני גם יכול לדבר על נושאים אחרים.
כן, אבל לא סתם. מבחינתכם, אם יש נושא שאתם רוצים שאני אחזור עליו אז אפשר לדעת מה יצא משם עם פרסום הפוסט.
רון? כן כן. אוקיי. כן. אחלה. אז אפשר להתחיל משם?
אמממ. אוקיי, אז מהו Masterpiece?
או אולי ניקח צעד אחד אפילו אחורה יותר? מה זה Dependent person?
כן, אתם זוכרים? אז כן הקלט וכן כן סיפרתי.
כן ביטוח מפני עלויות. אז היא כן סיפרה לי מה הקלט?
בתחילת משפט? משפט כן נכון משפט. אז נשמור משפט אחד.
מה אנחנו צריכים למצוא? עכשיו?
אם המשפט כן? אז בעצם לחזות עץ מכוון שפה?
קודם? כן.
אף אחד לא סיים. ובדרך כלל גם מוסיפים עוד דם minor root.
כן, אלה הקודקודים שלו וזה עץ מכוון עם עם שורש.
כן. אוקיי. ולפעמים אנחנו גם רוצים לחזות גרסה לייבל של זה.
נכון שזה אומר שאנחנו גם לכל צלח חוזים לייבל שהוא אחד מאיזשהו אוסף סגור של תגיות?
כן, אז בגירסה. לייבל.
לצלעות? יש תגיות?
מתוך איזושהי קבוצה נתונה.
אוקיי. אז הבעיה הזאת היא בעיה של structure production כמו שקראנו לזה.
אתם זוכרים מה ההגדרה של סטאק של production? מה זה אומר?
Struct של production לעומת סתם production? כן.
אז בדרך כלל כשאנחנו מדברים על דיקציה? כן.
נגיד, זה בדרך כלל הקונטקסט שלמשל באימייל לומדים דיקציה.
אז אנחנו מדברים בעצם על לחזות לייבל מתוך איזשהו אוסף של לייבל.
ולרוב אין תלות בין תופעות. לפחות במקרה הדיפולט אין תלות בין הטרדה לציות לשער.
זאת אומרת, אם יש לי כמה פרדיגמות לבצע, אז כל אחת מהן עומדת בפני עצמה.
כן, הצורה שבה אני, שבה אני מתייג את הפרדיגמה הבאה, לא קשורה לדרך שבה תיארתי את הפרי דיקציה הקודמת ב structure production.
אז בדרך כלל הכוונה כשמשתמשים במושג הזה לפרי דיקציה בעצם לאוסף של פרי דיקציה שיש ביניהם תלות שיש ביניהם איזשהו קשר סטטיסטי.
אז הדוגמה הראשונה ל structure Production שראינו בקורס זה כנראה.
סיקוונס כן, נגיד למשל Part of speech. כן, סיקוונס מודלינג ששם יש לנו סדרה של רדיקליות ולממשל בפרט speech tag.
זה מועיל לנו לדעת מה הפרה דיקציה של מה הלייבל של מילה אחת בשביל לדעת מה לא ידעו של מילה אחרת.
עכשיו הדבר הזה יוצר קושי נכון?
כי עכשיו במקום דיקציה, כל מילה למחלקה שלה מתוך אוסף של 30 מחלקות יש לנו נגיד עבור משפט באורך n יש לנו 30 בחזקת n פרוטקציות שאנחנו צריכים לבחור מהן,
אז באיזושהי צורה אנחנו צריכים לעשות את זה, להניח עוד הנחות, לעשות את זה באיזושהי צורה אינטליגנטית.
בעצם מקרה נוסף שראינו של Structure Tradition, למרות שלא תמיד חשבנו עליו דיקציה, זה פשוט הבעיה של טקסט Generation.
כן, גם בטקסט Generation, נכון?
נגיד למשל, תחשבו על ה Transformer Language models שדיברנו עליהם אנחנו חוזים בעצם רצף של מילים, אבל אנחנו לא מתייחסים אל זה כפשוט לחזות רצף.
כן, כן, דיקציה אחת. כי פשוט אז מרחב החיפוש יהיה עצום.
כן, יהיה אקספוננציאלי באורך הטקסט שאנחנו רוצים לחזור. אז מה אנחנו עושים שם שם?
מה שאנחנו בגדול עושים זה זה בעצם.
בדרך כלל מגדירים את צורת הפרויקטים שלנו עם מה שנקרא צורה אוטו אגרסיבית.
נכון שבה אנחנו חוזים מילה, מזינים אותה כחלק מהפרויקט, חוזים עוד מילה, מזינים אותה כחלק מהפרויקט וכן הלאה.
אבל כמובן שהדבר הזה הוא פוטנציאלי.
צד אופטימלי נכון, כי אולי איכשהו משהו שהיה נראה טוב לחזות בשלב מוקדם של הגנרל ציה התברר כלא כל כך טוב לחזות אחר כך איך אנחנו מתאוששים מזה.
אז אפשר לנסות כל מיני דרכים כמו בסרט שדיברנו עליו, ויש גם דרכים אחרות, אבל בגדול זאת לא בעיה פטורה כן?
אז באמת structure פה. כן, זה שיש לי אוסף אדיר של קציצות שבעצם תלויות אחת בשנייה.
שבמקרה של סנדוויץ מודל גם כל אחת מהן היא בין הרבה מאוד מחלקות.
כן. מה בעצם המחלקות כן, או על קלאסים האפשריים שלנו של מודל?
מה לאימוץ של מודל חוזה או כן את המילה או את התוכן הבא?
בעצם נכון? אז כבר שם המרחב הוא כנראה כמה עשרות אלפי מילים, אולי יותר מזה,
ובוודאי כשאנחנו מדברים על רצף שלם אנחנו מדברים על מספר שהוא אקספוננציאלי באורך והבסיס הוא כגודל אוצר המילים.
כלומר אנחנו מדברים על מספרים פנטסטיים וברור שאי אפשר לעשות שם Exact Insurance ועושים כל מיני סריקות שונות ומשונות.
טוב, אז בעצם ה MSC פרסר הוא איזשהו מודל שמניח הנחה מפשטת בכדי שנוכל לפתור את הבעיה הזאת בצורה
מדויקת כדי שנוכל לבצע expect influence וניתן האמת גם באופן עקרוני לעשות expect learning.
כן, אולי עם קצת כוכביות אבל לא משנה. אפשר לעשות את זה בצורה בצורה יעילה.
אוקיי, אז מה מראה מיסטי פרסר? רמז טיפ פרסר.
הוא מניח מה שקוראים לפעמים high factors מודל.
כן או high factors score and function score function.
זה אומר שהוא מניח score של עץ?
כן, נתיב של עץ. של עץ כן, בהינתן משפט.
הוא. יש לו צורה מיוחדת ששמה היא. אולי מהשם נרמז כבר מה זה אדג Factor.
מה הכוונה? אני רוצה שאני משקרת. סליחה, משקרת בקשר שכן שהוא בעצם מתפרק כסכום משקלי הצלעות שמכיל אותו.
אוקיי. כלומר, בעצם מה שהוא אומר זה שלכל צלע ששייכת לעץ.
יש איזשהו Score. כן, והסכום הזה הוא לא תלוי בשום צורה ב score של הצלעות האחרות.
אוקיי, זאת אומרת תמיד אם הצלע הזאת נכנסת היא מוסיפה לי score 8 נקודות.
נגיד, או כמה שזה לא יהיה score שם. אוקיי, באופן לא תלוי באיזה עוד צלעות יש או אין בעץ.
אז בעצם הוא מתפרק לצורה הזאת. אחרי זה גם דיברנו על Higher Order Features שבהם זה לא מתקיים.
נכון שבהם יש ספרים זה לא נראה ככה, אלא זה מתפרק.
איך למשל? In house הכסף הרב ממדי נכון?
מה שקורה זה זה שדיברנו שבעצם זה לא רק מתפרש כסכום על משקלי צלעות, אלא גם סכום על משקלי שלישיות מסוימות וכאלה דברים.
אוקיי, אפשר לדבר על זה אחר כך, אבל על כל פנים זאת ההנחה.
וכמובן שה Scope הזה הוא תלוי באיזה שהוא תטא בן הוא עצמו, איזה שהוא פונקציה נלמדת ובצורה הפשוטה ביותר שאותה למדנו בקורס זה פונקציה לינארית של תטא.
אוקיי, אז הסכום. E שייך ל t של תטא כפול.
איזשהו feature function. כן איזשהו feature function של הצלע הפוטנציאלית.
כן, אז אפשר לקבוע אותה על ידי לא משנה.
היא הלייבל של אי נגיד. המשפט.
כן, הצלעות שעם שהיא מחברת על הקודקודים שהיא מחבר הלייבל והמשפט כן, זה אי בריא בריבוע.
כן כן, זה המשפט. אוקיי.
מממ. מה זה השיר בעצם על? הנקודה הזאת?
זאת הפונקציה? מה? איזה פרמטרים אני מקבל? איי אל ו איקס או זוג קודקודים?
בעצם לייבל ובית המשפט.
כן. אה, בסדר.
וההפך הזאת היא איזושהי פונקציה ממשית. כן, שנותנת לי ערכים בדרך כלל בינאריים באיזשהו מרחב פיצ'רים ממימד D.
אוקיי, אז F זה איזושהי פונקציה. כן, אני אבוא בריבוע Fall כפול נגיד 10, אוסף המשפטים האפשריים לארבע שדי או לאפס אחד בדיוק.
אוקיי, אז זה פונקציית התכנוניות. עכשיו איך נראה העסק?
למה הדבר הזה מועיל לנו? זה שהחלטנו לסקור יש צורה מסוימת כזאת.
אוקיי, אז מה אתם אומרים? זה נראה מוכר דברים כאלה.
זה כאילו לא כל כך. כאילו אני מנסה להבין אם זה פשוט כי אתם לא זוכרים או כי אתם זוכרים את זה טוב.
אז איך אתם מרגישים עם החומר הזה? איפה הוא ברמה של בן?
זה נראה כמו הפעם הראשונה שאני שומע על זה לבין אני כבר יודע את זה בעל פה.
זה נראה מוכר ובכיר ניסח עיקרון זה. אני זוכר בגדול שלמדתי את זה, לא זוכר במאה אחוז.
צריך להשתמש בו כל הזמן. אוקיי, בסדר. כן כן. אוקיי, טוב אחלה.
אז איך נראה העסק? כן. מה זה עסק Influence?
מה זה Influence? כן, הוא השלב של הטסט.
כן בדיוק פספסת את העץ הכי טוב. אז כן. Influence.
אז מה שעושים בעסק? זה בעצם מקבלים משפט נכון וצריך למצוא את העץ האופטימלי.
כן, יש לנו כבר את תטא, אז מה אנחנו יכולים לעשות? בגלל זה אנחנו יכולים להציג את זה כבעיה של MSD.
כן, מסכים מכוון. נכון? אז אנחנו אומרים. כן.
אז בגדול אני יכול לעשות לכם תרגיל על זה. גם לא.
כן. אוקיי. כן. אנחנו מקבלים.
שפעת? כן, אבל בסין בונים גרף.
מלא עם עץ. כן. אז מלא מעט אני אומר.
כלומר חוץ מצלעות שנכנסות לרוץ. על.
על זה. נותנים לכל צלע משקל.
נכון שזה קל שצריך להפעיל את הפיצ'ר Function להכפיל ותטא.
כן מחשבים. נכון, לא נקרא לו G.
מחשבים? את משקלי הצלעות.
בג'י. ומוצאים את העץ המכוון.
את העץ המכוון הכבד ביותר שפורש את G.
עושים את זה כשהוא נוהג לומר כן, בדיוק כשזה כבר משהו שמישהו פתר, אז פשוט אפשר להשתמש בזה.
תן לי תחושה של מה שהוא אמר לך כל הזמן.
זה פשוט שם של שלושה חוקרים. שאל. לא, לא, לא נכנסנו לעומק של איך הם עשו את זה.
מי שמעוניין יש את זה בויקיפדיה או שכן?
אין שלל Tutorials. זה פשוט איזושהי בעיה.
קומבינטור. את מאמינה שאם אתה כבר מוטב, ואם לא אכפת לך אז.
אה כן כן, זה באמצעות.
שהוא לא אדמונדס.
אלגוריתם. מוציאים?
את העט. המחוון.
הכבד ביותר. קורס.
אוקיי. יש כאן איזושהי כוכבית קטנה שאם זה Labels אז בעצם אין לנו פה בדיוק גרף, אלא מה שיש זה.
מולטי גרף כן, אז להזכיר את הנקודה הזאת? כן אוקיי.
אם זה אם זה? Labels Pricing.
אז לחול. B1 B2 שייכים לווי של G?
כן יש L. צלעות.
ביניהן. אוקיי נכון אחד לכל אבל אפשרי.
בסדר אחד לסאב ז'קט אחד לאובייקט, טרמינל אחד וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
אז מה עושים? אז בעצם כן, איך זה נראה?
בואו ננסה להסתכל איך זה נראה. אז יש לנו root? כן, ויש לנו נגיד שלושה קודקודים.
סתם לשם הדוגמה. אוקיי. ויש לנו צלעות בסדר נרות יש רק צלע אחת שיוצאת ממנו כי זה תמיד רוטט.
זה לא נורא מעניין, אבל ביניהם יש.
עוד שתיים, אחת, שתיים, אחת שתיים וגם.
אחת, שתיים אחת.
בסדר, ואולי עוד צבעים. בסדר, עכשיו זה לא גראף.
נכון, זה מולטי גראף, אז איך אנחנו? אבל בעצם זה לא מסבך לנו את הבעיה יותר מדי.
למה? כי איך אנחנו יכולים להפוך אותו לגרף? אני לא באמת יכול לתת לך את המשימה להסביר על הסרטון של עצמך.
סליחה, כל פעם אתה צריך לחדש את המשימה לפני כן. בדיוק.
כי בעצם אנחנו שמים לב שאם נגיד הצלע הזאת אוקיי, שוקלת אחת והצלע הזאת שוקלת שתיים.
אז אמנם אני לא יודע אם זאת או זאת יופיעו בעץ הסופי, אבל מה שבטוח שזאת ששוקלת 1 לא תהיה פשוט להחליף אותה וזאת שלוקחת 2 שמני ששוקלת 2.
אז מה שאפשר לעשות זה פשוט לכל זוג קודקודים לזרוק את אלה הקלות יותר.
את כולם חוץ מאת אחת המקסימליות נגיד אם יש כמה.
וזהו. אוקיי, במקרה זה.
קודם. מסירים.
את כל הצלעות. בין V1 V2.
למעט אחת. כמה סימלי.
כן, אז כמובן שבאחד מהאקשן פה זה אולי הוא לצלע הכחולה, אבל בכיוון ההפוך או הלייזר צלע הוורודה נכון, ובכיוון הזה זה אולי הצלע הסגולה וכן הלאה.
כן, בסדר, אבל לכל אחד יש מקסימום לפחות אחד. שכן צריך לעלות על זה שהדף יהיה שוב כי תזכור מה אני עושה.
מה שאני, מה שאני עושה זה בעצם יש לי L צלעות אפשריות בין כל זוג קודקודים, נכון?
מה שאני עושה כאן בעצם זה מסיר את כולם חוץ מאחד עכשיו אין.
מבחינת קשירות של הגרף אין שום יתרון לצלע אחת לעומת אל צלעות ביניהם.
נכון? כאילו מה זה בעצם? כל עץ בהכרח ישתמש לכל היותר באחת מן הצלעות האלה.
נכון, זה אנחנו מסכימים. אוקיי, אז הוא ישתמש בכל היותר אחת מהן אם הוא ישתמש ב 0.
אז אוקיי, אז בטח אין לי בעיה לזרוק צלעות. ואם הוא ישתמש באחד?
זאת בהכרח תהיה הצלע המקסימלית ביניהן. למה?
כי אחרת אם היא לא מקסימלית, הייתי יכול להחליף לשנייה לאחת מאלה שכן לאחת מהאחרות הייתי מקבל עץ טוב באותה מידה מבחינת קשירות
ופריסה ומה שאני צריך וחוסר מעגלים כי זה עדיין שמחבר את אותם קודקודים אבל רק הייתי מרוויח משקל.
אוקיי. טוב.
אני יכול להסכים עכשיו שזה נעים להסכים איך להגיע, אף כי הוא ממש לא אומר את זה.
לדוגמה, ממש יצא מאז איך ייראה התת עץ הפורש?
כן, ממש כאילו לתת אפילו איזה משפט של חמש מילים או משהו כזה עם הלייבל.
כן, למה לא? חמש מילים. אוקיי, זה די הרבה צלעות, אבל בסדר.
אולי ארבע ארבע ארבע. אוקיי, טוב, אז יש לנו ארבע מילים, נגיד.
נגיד משפט או סתם מילים. מה לא נגיד משפט, נגיד ביג דוג ברק לאאודי או משהו כזה?
אוקיי, בסדר. אה, אז עכשיו איך נראה עץ?
האופטימלי? הוא נראה כף. הערות? זה לכאן ולכאן.
1. כן, ככה נראה העץ האופטימלי לעשות זה לייבל.
אורן leave a reply! אוקיי, אז בסדר, אז זה נקרא אדומות וזה נקרא בוא נקרא לזה פשוט לייבל מספר 1.
סתם לא נעים על עצמנו אז זה נקרא זה? לייבל מספר 1 זה לייבל מספר 2 ונעמי נלי ג'ק וזה ג'ק טייבל Modified.
3. אוקיי, וזה פשוט רות תמיד מה שיוצא מכל זה.
אוקיי, אז אנחנו מציירים את הגרף. אז איך נראה הגרף?
יש פה קוד ROOT? יש פה את קוד Big.
יש Dogs. פארק.
הסלעים. אוקיי, אז דבר ראשון יש את הצלעות מהירות לכולם.
שלהם יש רק לייבל אחד אפשריות. אוקיי, עכשיו יש לנו צלעות מסוג אחד עם לייבל אחד, אז זה כאן וכאן זה כאן.
זקן מזדקן, זקן אז בוא נרשום, זה מספר אחד.
איזה קטע בין דיג לברק? אה אופס. כן.
סליחה וגם כאן כן תודה. כאן וכאן.
כאן. וכאן וכאן.
כמה מילים זה כבר יותר מדי. כן. אוקיי, בסדר.
עכשיו לכל אחד מהם אנחנו נוסיף גם המצאות מקבילות מסוג 1 ומסוג 2 הן מסוג 2 מסוג 3.
נכון. אוקיי, אז? מה חסר לי?
מה טוב? אוקיי אחלה. אז זה סוג 2?
סוג שלוש. בסדר, לא נכון.
אוקיי, פספסתי את הבדיקה אבל בשתיים עשינו חץ.
כאילו למה עשינו בכל אחת משלושת הסוגים חץ כאן.
כל מילה לכל מילה! פנינה! אם אין את משחקי הכס נניח אז ברק זה רק סימן את ה i רק במטבח.
ללעוס את זה זו התוצאה. מה שעושים עלי הבנתי.
זה גם מה שבכל מקרה זה החלק העליון. העץ הזה אין לי אותו.
טוב, אני אנסה לחזור לכל האפשרויות כדי שזה יפרוס את זה. כן, הבנתי.
אוקיי, אז עכשיו יש לי את הגרף הזה. כן, מה אני עושה בשלב ראשון?
מחשב את המשקלים? אוקיי, אז בוא לא נעשה את זה, אבל עקרונית מחשב את המשקלים.
ועכשיו מה אני עושה? אנחנו מוציאים את הצלעות שהן לא מקסימליות.
בדיוק. אז לכל זוג סדור נכון, יש לי שלוש צלעות אפשריות, אחד מהם לפחות הוא מקסימלי, אז אני משאיר את אחד המקסימלי.
בסדר, אז עכשיו יישאר לי מכאן טוב למחוק אותם.
מה לעשות? יש בזה משהו מחדש. אוקיי, בסדר, אז אני.
מבין? אוקיי, אז ככה.
שזה המקסימלי כאן וכאן. אה.
אה לא, סליחה זה היה רוט. זה המקסימלי כאן וכאן כאן.
כן, זה לאו דווקא הנכון. כן, בסדר. לא תמיד אלגוריתמי אינדיקציה מדויקים.
וזה ירוק. זה ירוק? זה ירוק.
ואז היה לי כאן ורוד אז אני לא יודע.
זה ורוד, זה ורוד. אדום למטה ועוד אלכסון אחד.
אה נכון. אוקיי, אז כאן יהיה ורוד וכאן יהיה.
נכון? ואת זה בין אלה נכון?
לשם הדוגמא אוקיי, ועכשיו אנחנו צריכים למצוא כל אחד מהם.
יש לו משקל נכון ואנחנו צריכים למצוא את העץ הפורץ המקסימלי.
בסדר, יש די הרבה אופציות. Root חייב להיות.
השורש כן. כי אם.
If not for any other reason. בגלל שהוא היחיד שאין ממנו שום צלע שנכנסת אליו נכון?
כן. יש לנו אוסף של עצים, אז בוא נגיד שעכשיו נגלה שהעץ האופטימלי הוא לא יודע מה זה הצלע הזאת נכנסת בו וזאת.
וזאת סתם לשם הדוגמה. אז בעצם העץ שקיבלנו הוא.
העץ הבא? רות הולך.
זה היה שם בפינה למעלה דובס. ואז מדוקס יוצא לכל הצלעות.
לכל הקודקודים האחרים נכון גם בלי.
בר. או בצורה יותר מקובלת לכתוב את זה.
זה היה מתאים לעץ. או.
לאנגלי שזה היה מתאים לאיזה עץ. Dogs Watch Root.
אז כאן כאן כאן.
ואיזה צבעים כל הצלעות האלה יהיו? בוא נראה מה בחרנו.
בחרנו ירוק ירוק, לא ירוק, כחול, ירוק, ירוק, כחול ירוק זה ירוק ירוק כן.
אז זה בעצם ירוק ירוק?
וכחול נכון? רגע מה זה?
זה לא לדייק זה ירוק. כן, גם מתוך האדום לבד זה כחול לא זה ירוק זה שמאל למעלה.
דוג זה ימין למעלה. אה רגע זה ירוק שזה לברק זה דבר?
כן זה דבר טוב, זה נכון, אבל זה לא זה.
לא לא, זה בסדר. זה מסוכן? אוקיי, זה יכול.
לבדוק. סטטיק זה גם ירוק. וזה בסדר אז זה עץ?
זה העץ שהאלגוריתם המזהיר שלנו חזה. כן, זה שלוש, זה שלוש.
אגב, זה נחשב לו attachment score. כן.
כמה הצעות הוא הציע? אתם זוכרים מה זה attachment score? זה מספר הצלעות שהן משותפות בין העץ הנכון לבין העץ הלא נכון.
יש לייבל באן לייבל. אוקיי. לייבל אומר שגם לייבל צריך להתאים באד לייבל אומר.
שרק העץ. אז בוא נספור כמה צלעות יש. הצלע בין רוט לברק טעות.
הצלע בין ברק ל וודלי. טעות.
הצלע בין ביג לדוכס. נכון ואפילו label נכון?
נכון? והצלע בן ברק לדוגמא?
טעות. אוקיי, אז מתוך 4 צלעות יש אחת נכונה.
ואת זה גם היטאצ'י score גם הלייבל וגם האנגלי. יותר נכון כיוון.
אז מה התוצאה? כל החברות בשוק?
כן. אז ה attachments score. כן מסמנים אותה As הרבה פעמים אז יש las Vegas.
זה מספר הצלעות הנכונות חלקי סך כל מספר הצלעות.
זה הגולד סטנדרט. נכון, זה מה שחזינו. אז בוא נעבור עליהם.
יכול או לעבור על הצלעות כאן או לעבור לצלעות. כאן לא משנה כאילו זה יצא אותו דבר כי המספר הוא זהה.
אז בואו נסתכל, בוא נעשה את זה עכשיו בכיוון ההפוך. הצלע הזאת בין רות ל Dogs מופיעה בכל סטנדרט.
לא. X. הצלע בין. זאת בין ביג לדוב, בין דוקס לביג.
הופיע. כן, יש ללייבל נכון גם כן. אז זאב טוב.
מה עם הצלע הזאת בין דוקס לברק מופיעה שם?
לא? מה עם הצלע בין דוקס אלגרבלי? אה, לא.
אוקיי, אז כמה הצלחנו? אחת מארבע וזה גם הלייבל וגם האנד לייבל.
בסדר, נראה לי את זה. זה בעיה עם הקבוצה הנכונה.
אולי זה לא נכון? האן לייב בוא נגיד שכאן היית חוזה, נגיד שתיים, קטגוריה שתיים, אז לא היה לך בכלל לייבל The Hits.
ואז זה היה אפס מארבע, אבל זה היה נשאר אותו דבר.
אוקיי, אז זה על עצמו וזה על הלייבל הזה. זה על הצלעות עם הלייבלים וזה ההוצאות בלי הלייבל שאתה זורק אותן.
אז מה זה אומר? מה יהיה תמיד היחס בין Guys לעיר Las?
אם הוא יהיה קטן בדיוק אלא יהיה דורש יותר פשוט.
הפוך כן. אלה יש טוב יש יותר.
טוב. עכשיו הלמידה. אז איך נראית הלמידה?
אז אנחנו צריכים בעצם זה סופר בייס learning, נכון?
מה שאומר שיש לנו. מה?
אוסף של עצים נכונים? נכון.
אז? נתון אוסף של משפטים.
עם עצים? איך אנחנו לומדים?
מה הפרמטרים של המודל? מה אנחנו צריכים לאמן?
אני בעצים, משפטים ועצים זה ה training data אבל מה אנחנו רוצים לאמן?
מה הם הערכים שהאימון צריך לקבוע? צלעות ורגליים כן, אבל ספציפית מה?
איזה ערכים אתה מאמן? כאילו מה אתה צריך לקבוע בזמן training?
שאם אני נותן. עץ.
Label tree. איזה חלק שממנו נלמד בכל score function.
את צריך לבחור את הצבע. אתה צריך לבחור את כמות הצלעות.
אתה צריך לבחור את המשקל של צלעות נכון. על פי מה נקבע המשקל של הצלעות?
הצלעות עצמן נקבעות ב influence. נכון, זה ראינו קודם איזה צלעות, אבל לפי מה נקבע המשקלים?
נקבעים משקלים של הצלעות הפוטנציאליות. גם זה לא בדיוק בסדר.
אוקיי, אז אנחנו צריכים לאמן את טטה. איך מוצאים את טטה?
אז מה שאומר Perception זה בעצם ה social perception.
זה בעצם הוא אומר. מספיק לך לעשות לופ שבו יש לך גישה ל influence, כלומר איך זה נראה?
כן, אתה מתחיל מאיזשהו תטא, נגיד רנדומלי. כן.
או אפס או משהו? אוקיי, עכשיו אתה עובר.
אתה עושה איטרציות על הטרנד? Samples כן.
אז for? כן xi ci.
בוא נקרא לזה. איך מסמנים את זה בדרך כלל תראי על קליגרפיה.
תגיד אה כן, עם sum order ואולי כמה פעמים בסדר.
זה כרגיל בסיקסטיז. דברים שהם בסגנון סטוק סיטי, גרדיאן and in some other multiple city.
מה תעשו? תמצאו את העץ הטוב ביותר בהינתן התא הנוכחי.
אוקיי, כלומר תעשו ard max. על score.
כנהג מקס על T על כל העצים של המשפט הזה.
זה איך עושים איזה אלגוריתם בדיוק זה influence?
פשוט להריץ סעיף שדיברנו עליו קודם, נכון? אז יש לנו רעיון איך עושים את זה?
ועכשיו מה תעשו בעצם?
תסתכלו על ההפרש בין הפיצ'ר Function של התטא האופטימלי כנתבע הנכון Gold Standard ti לבין הפיצ'ר function של tag.
אז בעצם תסתכלו על ה score. של תטא של T הנכון.
לא אסקורט סליחה feature function score כאילו בלי התטא.
אז כאילו הפיצ'ר Function. בעצם סכום על האפסים.
איך סימנו את זה שם עם el ו x?
כן. היא l X.
I. על כל האי ואל בארץ הנכון.
אוקיי, זה סכום של כל feature Functions על הצלעות שנמצאות בעץ הנכון עם הלייבלים הנכונים שלהם, ונוריד מזה את הפיצ'ר Functions של מה?
שנכנס תחת שליטה מלאה בדיוק של הטייטל שחזינו.
אוקיי, זה כיוון העדכון. כלומר, אם אני עכשיו לוקח את זה, מכפיל אותו באיזה שהוא learning רייט כן, ומוסיף אותו לתא הקודם.
בוא נגיד שיש לי איי.
איי שווה אפס. טבעי שעושה זאת.
ועוד אחד. אוקיי, אז אני עושה את זה.
חוזר על זה כמה אפיקים? רנדום אורדר לפיקסל.
זה כל הדברים של סטוקר. סטיק אנד סאנס.
זה בעצם איזשהו בן דוד של לוקאס גריידי אנד סאנס, רק שאנחנו זה לא בדיוק הגרדיאנט, אלא איזשהו גורם אחר שראינו שהוא קשור לגרדיאן.
הגרדיאנט הוא מאוד דומה לזה עם שינוי קל. נכון שהוא מה אתם זוכרים?
מה שיוצא הגרדיאנט זה שפה צריך לקחת את התוחלת על פני כל העצים לפי ההסתברות מימד נכון מתגלה מימד של כל היקום הזה.
בגלל שיוצא שגורם ה נרמול הוא בעצם גורם לימוד שסוכם על כל העצים, אז אפשר עדיין לפתור את זה, אבל לא למדנו את זה וזה פחות שימושי איכשהו פחות Practice.
בדרך כלל משתמשים בדבר כזה ובסוף מחזירים לרוב את הממוצע על כל הטרקטורים של התטא.
זאת אומרת, בדרך כלל מחזירים את הממוצע ולא את זה.
אז נגיד אם סיימנו כן, כמה היה לנו כאן?
כן, אז ריתם. כמה שזה לא יהיה, כמה טעות יש לנו פלוס אחד.
לא, אבל עדיין נראה לי אחד אלא אם פספסתי פה באחד.
נראה לי שלא. אז זה משהו כמו. אה אה, אולי זה פלוס אחד?
גדול. אבל זה לא סיפור.
גדול אם גדול. לא, כי אני אומר אולי לא עברתי על כולם פעם.
אז כאילו כתבתי כאן זה בעצם לא הכוונה דווקא לעבור על כולם.
כן, זה אולי את רוצה לעבור על זה כמה פעמים? נכון.
אולי אתה רוצה לעבור על זה בסדר אקראי ולעשות רי Shuffle בין איטרציה לאינטראקציה?
כן, אלה כבר כל מיני דברים. אומרים כאלה שקשורים לך.
אתה עושה אופטימיזציה, אבל בגדול זה זה אלגוריתם.
אוקיי, שאלות לגבי זה. טוב אחלה.
אז בואו נצא להפסקה, נחזור עוד רבע שעה.
אגב, למישהו יש כאן כבל Lightning כזה שאיש לא הפסיק לעבוד?
איתו? קבוצה של.
אנשים. שם.
אגב, לא יצא לי לעבור במשך שנה את הסיפור.
על שיטת הבחירות. אה רגע, ככה זה התחיל.
מה שלמדתי זה מהעבודה. הקשה שעברה עם מצגת או משהו.
בשלב הזה זה שכבר לא צריך לעשות קצת סדר.
חשבתי שעכשיו הוא יעשה את זה חזרה ואז זה משהו שאני יכול ליישם שלו בכל פעם שאתה צריך.
משהו. אתה.
רואה את זה כאילו זה היה לא נעים. זה כאילו נפגע בבניין בחיפה.
זה באמת לא נורמלי. זה יכול להפתיע אותי כי אני לא מבין למה לא צריך לעשות משהו מיוחד שבכלל לא יקרה כאן.
אפילו לא צריך להבין איך זה עובד.
כולם. יודעים.
למה לא להכניס את זה כאן ואף הבנתי שאי אפשר.
להתעלם מן המוזיקה. מטאליקה באירופה.
זו גם הסיבה לכך. היא מזכירה מאוד את הפרויקט הזה.
שיתוף פעולה? כזה שאי אפשר לתאר.
אותו אתה יודע טוב.
מאוד. לא. רציתי לעשות מין של דמויות בידי גברים.
ונשים חזקות. יותר מדי.
עכשיו גם אני צריך לראות. אולי בכלל בכל השבוע הזה אני לא ממש חושב שזה מדעי המוח.
לא הבנתי. עד עכשיו הבנתי איזה ערך אמנותי אמרתי.
בואו נבחן חצי שעה. עכשיו הוא יושב ליד שער כאילו? לא.
עושה דבר. כאילו מה צריך לקרות?
אני אוהב את עצמי, מגיע לזה עכשיו. למה אני צריך לבחור בין השניים?
לא בטוח. הנה.
כן כן. יצאו.
ברכוש. המשותף שלי.
בוא נעבור רגע. הנקודה השנייה בסדר גמור, אבל גם לי יש הסדר עם סוכנות הנסיעות היה איתן מרקו.
סיקוונס גדול. מאוד.
כמו נדמה לי. לפני מספר שנים זה מה שאנחנו עושים עכשיו כל הזמן.
אבל אם לא עשו משהו לא בסדר, אולי לשים את זה קצת אחרת?
אז מה הבעיה שלך? טוב תראה, אני אקח אותך אחת הגרסאות היא של מה נחזור עכשיו?
על מה קורה אם לא יותר? מהם הדברים האחרונים שדיברנו עליהם?
אז ככה, אני לא יודע אם יש לי משהו בשבילך ואני מצפה לחדש את הסיפור מאחורי זה.
לא יודע מה. אתה חושב שאנחנו רוצים?
או לא צריכים לדעת איך זה נגמר? כן.
זה הכל. כן.
כן. טוב, אז מה הנושא הבא?
יש לי כמה הצעות. לא נראה שיש פה תחרות.
בוא נראה. Sichuan. וורדפרס? וורדפרס?
וורדפרס בעברית? אוקיי, אתה יכול קצת למקד אותי.
כן, הוא ממש לא משהו.
פשוט הצעתי דברים כלליים כדי שעוד מישהו יוציא מוזמן להיכנס לזה.
אה אוקיי. כל העסקית. טראנס?
אולי. מה סקיפ אסקייפ רמז? אוקיי, בסדר.
אחלה. אז מספיק ספציפית. כן.
כן. מעולה! אסקייפ רמז מי שזוכר מה זה סקייפ גם.
כן, לפעמים קוראים לזה וורד טוק. למרות שלי וורד דובק זה בעצם השם של החבילה שמכילה כמה אלגוריתמים בתוכו.
אנחנו למדנו את סקיפ גם, אבל בגדול זה שייך לתחום של Non padding.
זוכרים מה זה non קונטקסט עם Padding? מה ההבדל ביניהם לבין קונטקסט Police עם בלאנס?
שזה מתייחס למילים מאחורי המשפט בדיוק, כלומר לוקח מילה בדיוק כמו שהיא, בלי קשר בדיוק בדיוק.
אז בעצם אלה שיקולים של המילים בלי ההקשר שבו הם נמצאות, כלומר בלי התייחסות לשאר המילים במשפט.
אז אפשר בעצם לחשוב על זה כאיזה שהיא אגרגציה על פני כל המובנים והשימושים השונים של המילה?
כן, אז כל המובנים השונים שבהם המילה עשויה להופיע עם המילה רב משמעית.
רוב המילים הם במידה מסוימת במידה מסוימת לפחות רב משמעיות.
אז איכשהו עושה אגרגציה על כולם, נותן לכל אחת וקטור יחיד.
סקיפ גרהאם הוא גישה מסוימת באלגוריתם מסוים כדי לייצר קונטקסט Lived in Paintings.
ובעצם הוא מבוסס על. בעצם עניין קונטקסט.
הם מבוססים על רעיון שנקרא production base models production base models.
הרעיון הוא שזה רעיון שגם אחרי זה ראינו אותו בפרי טריינינג עם נושא של פרי טריינינג.
זה שבעצם אנחנו מגדירים איזשהי משימה איזושהי Task.
קוראים לזה לפעמים כן איזושהי משימה שלרוב אין בה עניין לכשעצמה.
כן, במקרה שלנו כאן זה יהיה לחזות את השכן של המילה, כי המילה שמופיעה סביבה באיזשהו חלון זה לא משימה שלרוב יש לה איזשהו.
כן, אינדיפנדנט interest. אבל הרעיון הוא שאם באמת השכנים של המילה זה קראנו distribution hepatitis.
כן, אם באמת השכנים של המילה מגלמים ידע סמנטי או התפלגות השכנים של המילה מגלמים ידע סמנטי לגבי המילה עצמה,
כך שמילים דומות סמנטית מופיעות בהקשרים דומים עם שכנים דומים.
אז אם כך, להיות מסוגל להשיג ייצוג שהוא מהווה איזושהי דחיסה?
כן, איזשהו קידוד של התפלגות השכנים של המילה, שזה בעצם מה שהאלגוריתם לפרש דיקציה של השכן של המילה.
צריך לעשות כן, למצוא איזשהו ייצוג שבאמצעותו יהיה ניתן באופן אפקטיבי לחזות את התפלגות השכנים.
אז הייצוג הזה הוא בעצם אפשר לחשוב עליו כייצוג של ההתפלגות של השכנים, ולכן אפשר לחשוב עליו כאיזשהו ייצוג סמנטי של המילה.
אוקיי, אז זה בערך הרעיון? כן. אז הרעיון ברור.
אוקיי. ועכשיו לטכניקה. אז הטכניקה היא די פשוטה.
אוקיי, הטכניקה היא די פשוטה. היא אומרת בעצם את הדבר הבא.
מה שאני רוצה לחזות זה בעצם בהינתן מילה נכון, בהינתן מילה הכוונה מילה מחוץ להקשר.
כן, מילה מתוך אוצר המילים כן, בוא נקרא לזה. לא יודע אם U שייך לה.
Category כן, אנחנו נרצה לחזות.
כן, נרצה לחזות את זהות שכנה.
עכשיו מה הכוונה? שכנים של מילה הכוונה בשכנים של מילה זו?
זו הגדרה קצת שרירותית, אבל בגדול לוקחים.
בדרך כלל לוקחים איזשהו חלון מסביב למילה ששם אנחנו מניחים נמצאים השכנים הרלוונטיים ביותר מבחינה סמנטית ואותו אנחנו מקודדים.
כן, אז זה לא חלק מן האלגוריתם. זה לגמרי בדיקה.
תגדירו שכנים איך שאתם רוצים. בסדר. תוציאו בקורפוס שלכם דוגמאות אימון, כלומר מילים ושכנים.
אוקיי, ואז תאמנו את זה.
זה לא כל כך משנה איך הוצאתם אותם. כן, זה לגמרי בסדר.
אז כן. אז בהינתן הגדרה? לשכנות ניקח קורפוס ונחלץ.
זוגות? כן. איור V.
אחים לוי בריבוע. תחשבי שכן שלך.
למעשה אפילו היו עבודות שהשתמשו בהגדרות של שכנות שמבוססות על תחביר.
כן, נגיד, אמרו אני לוקח רק את הדיפנדר ואת הדיפנדר של הדיפנדר שלי בתור שכנים.
כן, אין עם זה בעיה. כל עוד יש לכם איזושהי הגדרה שאתם יכולים להפעיל אותה על כמויות של דאטה ולייצר זוגות זה בסדר.
עכשיו מה אתם עושים? אז איך מוגדר המודל? אז המודל אומר ככה? כן, המודל מוגדר.
כך. בעצם אנחנו אומרים שההסתברות.
של v שכן בהינתן u.
V אכן של u בהינתן לו. למה היא שווה?
היא בעצם שווה ל soft max של. כן, היא שווה בעצם ל Soft Max של מכפלה של שתי מטריצות אחת שמייצגת את V ואחת שמייצגת אותי.
אז בואו נרשום את זה. נגדיר.
להיות כן, אז מטריצה שהיא.
כן, העמודות שלה הן המילים באוצר המילים. נגיד נקרא לזה קצת במיוחד.
בגודל של V. אוקיי, המימד שלה הוא איזשהו D.
זה היפר פרמטר. אוקיי.
שאלה כמה אנחנו רוצים שהמודל שלנו יהיה אקספרסיבי בכמה מימדים?
אנחנו רוצים לייצג את המילים? אוקיי. ויש לנו איזשהו תג.
כן, שהוא בעצם יש לו מימדים הפוכים לזה.
כן. אז. כן, יש קו אחד.
בסדר גמור. כל וקטור זה מייצג מילה ואוצר מילים.
מצב. כן, אבל אפריורית. אלא פשוט מטריצות. כאילו אלה פרמטרים נלמדים של המודל שמאבחנים רנדומלית ותהליך ההחזרה דווקא בהכרח שגם חצי דיגיטלי כן.
לא לא לא. ממש לא. זה מושגים למרות שהם כביכול מייצגים.
לא, זה לא טרנס פוסט אחד של השני. זה פרמטרים אחרים. אוקיי.
אז אלה פרמטרים. אוקיי, אז אלה הפרמטרים.
ועכשיו ההסתברות של V שווה u של הסתברות של V.
למה היא שווה? בעצם מה שאנחנו צריכים לעשות זה לקחת את הדאבל של U.
כן, נגיד שהיו זה האינדקסים. אוקיי, אז אנחנו צריכים לקחת את הדאבל U.
אוקיי, להכפיל אותו. של מי שמתאים לו שמתאים לו זה מכפלה מכפלה פנימית.
זה נותן לנו איזה שהוא מספר ממשי, נכון? ועכשיו לזה אנחנו צריכים לעשות סוף.
מקס בסדר, אז בעצם מה שזה יוצא זה.
E בחזקת w. U. חלקי סכום על פני כל האוויר על פני כל ה.
לא יודע מה זה. לאוצר המילים של איי דאבליו יום.
ואיך מאמנים. ההגדרה ברורה, אבל אנחנו לא נסתכל על זה במובן התדריך תרצה של TLV.
אתה מחזיק את זה? יש לך שאלה למודעות וזה של השורות. אז מה זה בדיוק התוצאות של העמודה בתוך שורה?
אז זה לא זה. אתה לוקח את הוקטור הזה?
מכפיל אותו מכפלה פנימית. אתה מקבל סקלר. זה מכפלה פנימית.
כן, כן, מכפלה פנימית. בסדר. אוקיי, אז מה הרעיון?
הרעיון הוא שהאלגוריתם הזה אמור למצוא מה לחשוב על זה.
אינטואיטיבית הוא אמור למצוא לכל מילה וקטור.
כן ולמצוא לכל מילה לכל שכן אפשרי שזה תכלס גם בדרך כלל כל מילה, אלא אם אתם מגבילים את זה באיזושהי צורה למצוא לה וקטור.
אוקיי, וקטור שמייצג את המילה הזאת כשכונה פוטנציאלית.
ועכשיו ככל ווקטור של מילה יותר דומה ל וקטור שכן.
אוקיי, זה אומר שמילה אחרת.
זה אומר שיותר סביר שהם יהיו שכנים. בסדר.
זה הגיוני גם שזה יהיה שניהם שונים, נכון? כי אחרת יוצא שהמילה שהכי כאילו שהמילה שהכי סבירה להיות שכנה של מילה היא היא עצמה.
זה לאו דווקא נכון, כמובן. אוקיי, אז אוקיי, אז מאמנים את זה.
איך מאמנים? פשוט מקסימום לייק. לימוד. כן, סימון לא למדנו בדיוק איך עושים את זה, אבל בגדול זה לא.
אפשר לעשות את זה בדרכים סטנדרטיות של אופטימיזציה.
כן, מה שרוצים למקסם זה את הלוג לייק ליהוד של כן W דאבליו תג שזה שווה ל log של מכפלה על פי וי.
איי. בהינתן יו. איי. נגיד לכל דוגמאות האימון זה שווה לסכום לוגים.
גם אני וגם אביו. שניהם חיים במרוץ כזה כי זה לא סתם.
לא התכוונתי שה training. כן. אז ה training set או.
I vi. כאילו לא התכוונתי שהם אותה מילה אלא סתם אינדוקס כי לא ראיתי שיש לי פונקציה לשניהם.
תוכן עניינים? כן. כן. כן. אוקיי.
ועכשיו נגיד שעשינו את זה. הרי אנחנו לא באמת מתעניינים במודל שיוכל למצוא שכנים.
זה רק salary task, נכון? מה אנחנו? למה עשינו את כל התהליך הזה בשבילנו?
מדינה משלהם? בית דין? אוקיי. ואז מה עושים?
לפעמים מקניטים כאילו אומרים או שהייצוג של מילה זה פשוט הייצוג כאן.
כן לפי W וזורקים את אבל זו Tag. או שלפעמים מקלקלים אותם או סוכמים אותם או כל מיני דברים כאלה.
אבל בגדול לכל מילה מתאימים וקטור שמבוסס על וקטורים שלה ואולי גם.
מה שאני כן קורא באימון ADD כי בעצם ה p הזה מפתח אותו הוא בעצם המכפלה.
הסקלרים. פחות גורם פחות לא גורם נרמול. כן.
בעצם אתה מנסה למצוא עם Padding, כך ששכנים.
בעצם מה זה אומר? אתה מנסה למצוא עם Padding, כך ששכנים שהופיעו יחד ב training Data יקבלו מכפלת סקלרים גבוהה.
אבל מצד שני, אתה לא רוצה יותר מדי להגדיל את סכום המכפלות.
הסקלרים נכון, כי אחרת, באופן טריוויאלי, אתה יכול פשוט להגדיל לכולם את המכפלה.
הסקלרים נגיד על ידי זה תכפיל אותם בסקלר. נכון? אז עכשיו המכפלה השכלית של כולם גדלה?
אולי זה לא רעיון טוב? אז אתה איכשהו רוצה.
המכפלה השכלית שלהם תהיה גדולה ביחס למטפלות השכליות הכלליות.
כן, שהופיעו עם אותן מילים עם אותם עילויים.
בסדר. זה בעצם מה שאתה רוצה למקסם.
את שאלות. טוב.
היה לנו עוד משהו בהקשר הזה. שוב, רק אם זה עוזר לכם.
כן, אם כאילו יש לכם דברים אחרים להתעסק בהם זה בסדר.
חופשה שנתית. הבנתי ש 20 אחוז מהחומר אמור לרדת או משהו כזה.
כן, אני צריך בדיוק לקרוא את קיבלתם את התקנון הזה.
אני צריך לקרוא בדיוק מה אני צריך לעשות עם זה, כמה הם אמרו לי כמה ימים לפני המבחן צריך להודיע שחלק לא מופיע נכון.
משהו כזה כן, אבל כמה ימים לפני המבחן זה עוד חודש מעכשיו.
וכן, יש כאלה שהתחילו ליפול בעבודה אז לא יודע מה עובד לך.
אני אשמח בדין כל יום כבר מעכשיו. אז זה למידה עמוקה.
הודיעו כבר מעכשיו לפחות שהמבחן הוא בשלושה ארבעה שבועות.
אז כאילו אמרו שחייבים כאילו להודיע כמה ימים לפני המבחן, אבל אני מניח שזה כן יעזור אם יגיעו כמה שיותר טוב.
אני אתייעץ עם אם עם שאר הסגל או עם הסגן דיקן להוראה ואני אראה מה הנהלים ולפי זה אני משחרר.
כן. ובנוסף, אם תחזור קצת על גודל הטקסט שבכל המבנה הזה.
כן. Transformer. כן. אוקיי. טוב.
אחלה. אני מרגיש כמו בחינה בעל פה כמו שצריך באונליין.
כן. טוב.
אוקיי, אז זה encounter disorder. דבר ראשון מה זה ה transformer?
מה הוא עושה? מה הקלט ומה הפלט שלו? Encounter disorder transformer?
אבל משפט רציני לעבר נכון זה הדיקור.
דר אונלי והנקודה Recorder. מה הוא מקבל?
בית המשפט? את איזה משפט נגיד תרגום?
מה הוא מקבל? אבל יש משפט בשפה אחת.
כן, משפט המקור. מה זה הביקורת הזאת? מוציא את המשפט בשפה אחרת.
אוקיי, אבל מה הכוונה מוציא את המשפט? הוא מוציא את כל המשפט פלט שלו.
זה משפט כל פעם מוציא בוקר אחד כאילו אוקיי או או באופן יותר מדויק.
מה הוא מוציא מטבע וקטור כאילו וקטור התפלגות?
אוקיי, אז בעצם? כן.
Transformer או Transformer הוניל Transformer עם Power Recorder הקלט שלו זה משפט.
מקור. נגיד המשפט שנכנס לעין קודר נכון?
בוא נקרא לו X1 עד XL. וריש של פלט.
נקרא לו נגיד y עד y m. כן והפלט שלו הוא.
התפלגות על y m פלוס 1 בהינתן.
X1. נכון.
התפלגות על פני אוצר המילים. חשוב על ההנחה שהגודל של הכלב הוא כגודל הפלס.
אני לא סימנתי M ואין לי אף אחד כן, אז לא בסדר.
מה שכן מניחים זה שגודל הקלט הוא קבוע בין כל המשפטים.
זה פשוט עושים על ידי Padding. כן. אבל אוקיי.
מה עכשיו? אז איך נראה Recorder recorder ב high level?
הוא נראה ככה. יש את הצד של ה Encounter. כן, זה הצד שלה Encounter.
הצד של הנקודה הוא בעצם רשת עמוקה. שמקבלת רק את X.
כן. מה היא עושה עם הסדרה טוקנים האלה.
אוקיי, כל אחד מהתכנים פה. דבר ראשון צריך לעבור איזשהו Investing.
Padding הזה מורכב משני רכיבים. אחד מהם זה Padding של המילה עצמה, כאילו של הווארד form.
נכון נגיד dog או cat או cat או char.
והשני, מה הוא חשב עליהם קודם? מיקום המיקום בדיוק כן Encoding של המיקום.
זאת אומרת, עוד יש לנו עוד פרמטרים שזה בעצם וקטור לכל אחד מן המיקומים האפשריים.
בסדר, אז בעצם יש לנו שתי מטריצות עם Padding עם Padding אחד של המילים.
כן, אז פה יש את אוצר המילים. על D טקסט בלי בלי בלי בלי זה מהסוג שלנו.
Context של Like. כן, אז כאן יש מילה לדוג כאן Vector לדוגמא vector לכן ווקטור Sleep.
ויש לנו עוד DW אחר שהוא גם עם מימד D.
אבל פה יש את המיקומים האפשריים. כלומר זה אחד עד גודל הקונטקסט.
כן הגודל. הגודל של משפט המקור כן.
אוקיי, ואלה פרמטרים שלרוב מאומנים. אחרי שלקחנו אותם כל מילה, אפשר למצוא לה את הוקטור שמתאים לה פה ואת הוקטור שמתאים לה פה נכון לפי המיקום והמילה.
נחבר אותם ועכשיו יש לנו עם Padding לכל אחד מהמילים.
אוקיי, אז אחרי השכבה הראשונה הזאת שנקראת בדרך כלל האם padding layer?
כן, אז בואו נגיד נסמן את זה, נהיה צפוף.
אוקיי, אז דבר ראשון כל האיקסים. נכנסים עם Padding layer.
כן, שיש לו את המטריצות האלה. עכשיו מה שקיבלנו זה וקטור לכל אחד מהם.
נכון וקטורים Padding. ועכשיו קיבלנו V1 עד V.
עכשיו הדבר הזה בעצם הולך להיכנס לסדרה של בלוקים, שכל אחד מהם הוא בעצם self attention, ואז Emp למולטי להיות Perception כאילו פולי.
פולי connect אוקיי, פולי Connect, אם אתם מכירים עוד מהימן אז אני אתמקד ב self attention.
אוקיי, אז. אבל בגדול יש לנו כאן n שכבות. איזשהו n גדול שכבות של.
Self attention. שכל אחד מן הווקטורים האלה עובר אותם.
כאילו הם בעצם כולם עוברים ביחד גרסה לפטנט של שילוב על כולם.
עכשיו אוקיי, תכף נדבר איך עובד ה self attention, אבל מה שיוצא מכאן זה סדרה של וקטורים.
כן, בואו נקרא להם V אחרי האחד שהם בעצם הקידוד של הקלט.
אוקיי שהוציאה Encounter. זה משהו שאני צריך רק פעם אחת לכל תרגום, כי זה יישאר זהה עבור כל הרשתות השונות.
כן, אם אני עכשיו מתחיל משפט הרישא שלי היא ריקה. זה יהיה עם Padding מסוים.
אחרי זה אני אמשיך כבר. הרישא שלי תכיל Token בודד.
מה שבחרתי להיות התוכן הראשון עדיין יהיה אותו דבר.
נכון, זה אותו חישוב. זה לא משתנה, זה חלק. זה מבוסס רק על האיקסים שהם חלק מהקאסט.
אוקיי, אז יפה, אז עשיתי את זה.
שמרתי את הווים האלה. סיימתי כרגע עם אינקה.
עכשיו מה הוא עושה? הבדיקה Oder מה הוא מקבל?
הוא מקבל את ה Y? בסדר.
גם לו יש עם padding layer. באותו אופן כמו blind powder.
כן, זה סופר בהיסטריה, כי אם יש לך את הווילון זה סוג זה.
בכל מקרה סופר ויסלר כן. לא דיברנו על Transformer, כאילו קראנו לזה סלף סופר בייס לפעמים,
שכאילו אתה בעצם מייצר בעצמך את התנאים Big Data על ידי זה שאתה לוקח פיקסלים של משפטים אמיתיים ואת המילה הבאה ומנסה לחזות אותה, אבל זה עדיין טכנית.
זה סופר ויסלר. כן, אוקיי, אז יש לך עם padding layer.
עכשיו יש שוב זה מוציא? כן, בוא נקרא להם לא יודע מה U אחד תג או U אחד אודיו n.
אוקיי, והם נכנסים ל. כאילו לרשת העמוקה שגם היא בנויה מבלוקים רק יותר בלוקים.
נגיד שגם פה יש אין או אולי זה אין תג. כן, זה לא חייב להיות אותו מספר.
עקרונית שגם בה יש בלוקים אתם זוכרים אולי.
אז הבלוקים הראשונים נראים ממש כמו של ה Encounter. פשוט עכשיו הם עובדים על הפרי פיקס.
כן, החלק הראשון זה s a self attention ואז MC.
אוקיי, אבל זה מתעלם לגמרי מהשורשים.
זה לא כדאי, נכון? אז בשלב הבא אנחנו עושים.
אממ. כן כן, רק אולי צריך. תכף אני אגיד על זה הערה כי זה כן יש שינוי קטן ביחס ל Encoding, אבל זה כמעט זהה.
בשלב הבא יש לנו cross extension. שאליו אנחנו מזינים גם את מה שיצא מכאן וגם את ה output של ה Encounter.
אוקיי, אז בעצם עושה extension על שניהם ושוב פולט סדרה של וקטורים שנכנסת ל NLP.
וחוזר על זה אין פעמים ואז אנחנו מקבלים את.
לא יודע מה U1 תג עד יורו.
אוקיי, עכשיו מה הדבר שכן רציתי להגיד פה שהוא חשוב.
זה שכאן זה לא בדיוק העניין. כתבתי בהתחלה של self attention כמו שראינו.
אבל כן, יש פה הבדל. אוקיי, בעצם מה שאנחנו עושים זה אנחנו עושים פה מה שנקרא muscle attention.
כן, אז זה? שהוא מאוד דומה לסוג attention הרגיל, אבל יש לו שוני אחד מהותי.
אני תופס את זה מס. מה ההבדל שלו?
ההבדל שלו הוא שהם self attention.
בעצם הוא כל פעם לוקח קומבינציה של כל התקנים שנמצאים גם משמאלו וגם מימינו.
Means that mention יכול להסתכל רק על העמודה שלו ואחורה, כן, רק על האינדקס שלו ואחורה.
כלומר, כשאני מייצר את הווקטור החמישי, מותר לי להסתמך על הפלט של השכבה הקודמת במקומות 1 עד 5 אבל לא 6.
אוקיי, אז ככה זה עובד. כל פעם זה רק מסתכל אחורה.
אז את הראשון הוא מוציא רק על סמך עצמו. כן, את ה Token הראשון זה רק על סמך עצמו.
התו הוא כן השני זה על סמך עצמו ועל סמך הראשון, השלישי על סמך הראשון והשני והשלישי וכן הלאה.
זה חשוב מסיבות של יעילות חישובים, כי אחרת תחשבו בעצם מה אנחנו עושים.
אנחנו הולכים עכשיו להפעיל את הדיקור דר הרבה פעמים.
למה? כי כן, התדירות זה הרבה.
כי בעוד שהנקודה עושה חישוב אחד ותמיד זה אותו חישוב, אז בהתחלה צריך לפלוט התפלגות על פני המילה הראשונה ואחרי זה על פני המילה השנייה.
בהינתן הראשונה ואחרי זה המילה השלישית. בהינתן שתי הראשונות בכל אחד מהם זה הרצה חדשה של הטרנספורמציה.
הרצה חדשה של הדיקור דר. נכון, כי הפלט שלו ישתנה עכשיו אם לא היינו עושים מאז קצת attention שמסתכל אחורה,
היינו צריכים כל פעם לחשב מחדש את העין ב Things, את הכוס, את ההתנגשות על פני כל המילים.
כאן אנחנו יכולים לעשות Caching כי הוא מסתכל רק אחורה בגלל שהוא מסתכל רק אחורה.
אז זה אומר שכשהוא מחשב את עם Padding כן, כשהוא מחשב בעצם את הווקטור של המילה החמישית פה?
כן, הוא יכול להסתמך על האם Padding של 1 עד 4 שאולי הוא חישב כבר, או של כן של 1 4 שהוא חשב בסיבוב הקודם כי הם לא השתנו.
הם יסתכלו רק אחורה. הן לא יכולות להסתכל קדימה לחמישי. אוקיי, אז בעצם הדבר הזה מאפשר Caching אז זה דבר מועיל.
ו. אוקיי, אבל זה בגדול השינוי היחידי. אז זה עושה משהו שדומה לסלף attention אבל הוא מסתכל רק כיוון אחד רק אחורה.
MP אחרי זה cross attention, כלומר attention גם על ה output של זה וגם על ה Encounter עושה את זה n פעמים.
בסוף קיבלנו וקטורים כאלה. מה עושים איתם? קיבלנו וקטורים באיזשהו מימדי כלשהו.
כן. מה עושים בסוף? מה כן בדיוק מכפילים במטריצה שמעבירה אותם למימד של אוצר המילים?
כן, איזשהו production matrix. אז כאן יש לנו בעצם output ים, אז יש לנו סוג של עם Padding או output עם padding layer.
כן. שזה מכפיל אותה באיזושהי מטריצה.
לפעמים היא זהה למטריצה שפה ולפעמים היא זאת שפה זהה למטריצה שפה, אבל זה לא מחויב להיות על זה.
תגים? או אז גם כאן יש עכשיו וקטור לכל Token אפשרי ב output והוא כן.
We again 1. אז? כן.
אז בעצם אנחנו מקבלים את הוקטור הזה. כופלים אותו במטריצה לשים סוף.
Max? בעצם הדבר היחידי שאכפת לנו ממנו זה על האחרון.
כן, כי האחרון נותן לנו את ההתפלגות על פני המילה הבאה. כן.
אז בעצם מה שאנחנו בדרך כלל עושים זה לוקחים רק את U.
המתג כן, ואז מה שיוצא לי פה מהסוף מקס זה כן, זה בעצם p של y m פלוס אחד.
אוקיי. יפה אז זאת הארכיטקטורה שלך לגבי זה?
כן, אתה סוף סוף מקס.
כלומר על כל ה קילו אני אראה בסוף מה ההסתברות שזה יהיה טעון.
כאילו כל מילה הוא כן עם האפשרי. כן, עצם Words.
נכון, בשיעור הקודם דיברנו על זה שזה לא בהכרח מילים. זה הרבה פעמים משתמשים בחתיכות של מילים או ממש תווים בודדים.
זו ארכיטקטורה ב high level. איך עובד האימון? מה דוגמאות האימון שלי כאן?
משפטים יש עשרות. נכון. ועכשיו קצת יותר ספציפית.
אז איקס אחד עדיף לסיים עם בטן אם צריך גירוי. אחד הדברים הם שזה קיים בשפות שונות.
כן, אבל Y אחד אבל Y אחד. וואי אם הוא פרי Fix הוא לא תרגום שלם.
אז מה אתה עושה? נגיד יש לך עכשיו זוג משפטים?
כן. הלכתי הביתה בריצה ולא יודע.
I went home running. אז יש לך?
אז איך אתה מייצר מזה זוגות של אה, בעצם אתה צריך לקבוע מה X נכון מה איקס אחד אדם מה y אחד עד m ומהו Y?
הם פלוס אחד שהוא כאילו הלייבל שאתה רוצה לחזות.
נכון אפשר לעשות אז עושים כן.
אז מה שנקרא Teacher force. כן, זאת אומרת אתה לוקח כל פעם traffic, נכון?
אתה אומר אם יש לי משפט. כן, אם יש לי משפט.
אז מה דוגמאות האימון? שאני יכול להוציא מזה?
מיקסים מהוואי מהוואי הם פלוס אחד. זו לא שאלה קשה.
כן? כאילו בריצה אני אז בריצה הביתה.
עומס זה גם הרבה בריצה נניח ואז בריצה הביתה כמובן.
כן כן, זה האיקסים, זה האיקס? כן אז זה X1?
זה X2 זה X3. אוקיי.
מה זה? ומה עם הוואי? אז בעצם יש כאן כמה דוגמאות אימון כן.
דוגמה ראשונה בהינתן האיקסים האלה והפרי פיקס טריק לחזות מה y פלוס אחד i i הלייבל הנכון הוא i.
דוגמה שנייה בהינתן כל האיקסים והעין של פרי פיקס I, אז אחרי זה היא יורדת נכון?
וכן הלאה. אז אין. קראנו לזה Teacher force. אוקיי, כלומר, אנחנו מאמנים את המודל על רכישות של תרגומים נכונים.
האם בהכרח משהו ייתקל בו באינטרנט עם רישות של תרגומים נכונים?
לא נכון, כי אולי הוא עצמו ייצר רישות לא נכונות.
כלומר, יש כאן זה מה שלפעמים אומרים שזה אי ההתאמה בין האימון לבין הטסט לבין האינטרנט.
כן, בסדר, ויש כל מיני דרכים לנסות להתמודד עם זה.
לא מאוד נכנסנו אליהם. העיקרית שבהן היא Ring Force Learning שהזכרנו בשיעור הקודם.
אבל זה ברור. הנקודה הזאת כן, כי זו נקודה שלפעמים ככה מפספסים כי היא קצת עדינה.
אוקיי, אז אחרי שגילית שככה עושים במקרה כזה פיצ'ר Force?
כן, אני מתאמן על רגישות של תשובות נכונות. כלומר כן, זה תמיד יהיה פיקס שזה נכון.
3. נכון, אבל הלוואי.
אחד הדברים שלי משתנה שפעם אחת זה נמחק אי פעם שמעתי.
I want. כן, פעם אחת זה יהיה המחרוזת הריקה. אחרי זה זה i went.
אחרי זה i. I. כן בדיוק. ואף פעם אני לא אבקש ממנו נגיד.
הנה האיקס שלי הוא הלכתי הביתה בריצה. הפרי פיקס שלי הוא She.
בטח זה את המילה הבאה. אה כזה לא? כן כן.
אז עכשיו, אם בטעות הוא חזה את זה בתור המילה הראשונה באינטרנט טיים, אז מי יודע מה יקרה?
זה כאילו החשש בעצם. אוקיי. זה גם לא עושה חסד עם הגוף שלנו ולא לוקח את כל היסודות.
כן, הוא תמיד נשאר מלא בגלל זה עברנו של ה x.
אפשר פשוט לעשות Caching כאילו להריץ אותו פעם אחת. הוא אף פעם לא משתנה עם Padding.
כל הזמן משקל איטרציה משתנים אבל תודות ל masks attention.
אז אתה כן יכול לעשות להם Caching כאילו לכל מה שהיה עד אותה נקודה.
למה בעצם המגזין משתנה במקביל לבדיקות?
Dr. פשוט אני מתכוון לומר שאתה כל פעם מוסיף עוד עם Padding.
אתה מחליף Pads דברים שהם היו פשוט Padding Token ב Token אמיתי, אבל רק את הפקטורים הספציפיים של הבדיקה.
נכון? נכון, אבל זה תודות למס attention. נכון שאתה אוסר עליו להסתכל קדימה?
כן. אז נכון. אוקיי. טוב, אז נצא להפסקה.
מה התכנון לאחרי ההפסקה ואנחנו נכין בינתיים.
טוב אוקיי. נכון. לרגע.
זה לא. כל כך קיבלנו אותו.
זו הבעיה האמיתית. אוקיי. יהיה בסדר.
טוב, אז קצרים. זה היה בסדר.
אז יאללה. עכשיו לא נכנס לנו אחרי שאף אחד?
לא. נשאר בחוץ.
עכשיו? זה כל מה?
שיש לי, חשבתי. לעצמי.
זה מה שקורה. לא, זה לא קשור.
פה יש צילומים של שלוש דמויות.
בדיוק. בן גנב לעצמו שתיים שלוש.
תזכיר לי את זה, זה משהו אחר. חוץ מזה? שמתן תפס את הבת שלך התחלנו לעשות.
כאילו מתי אתה חושב שתשים את זה מאחורה ביחד? קבענו בשבוע הבא.
זה? לא סוד. כולם כבר.
יודעים את זה לכל הרוחות. זה? ממש.
אבל בקורס הזה. אתם עוברים את זה.
אי אפשר לישון לילה אחד אחרי זה.
פשוט הולך מיד אחרי השיר הזה וגם את הביצוע שלו. אוקיי, איך קיבלנו את בדרגת מורה אחד?
וואי. איך קיבלנו את וואי איך אני מסתכל על זה.
נניח באטמן סטיישן? סבבה. התחלתי לתרגל. יש לי את ה, יש לי את ההתחלה של המקור.
יש לי את זה מהאינטראקציה הקודמת. אוקיי, אבל ממש בהתחלה.
אתה פשוט רמה. כל פס אמרתי סליחה ממש בהתחלה זה היה יכול לעשות עבודה טובה.
זה הכל Padding. וזה יעבוד.
כאילו למה לא בדיוק? זה גם עובד, גם טוב.
כן, זה טוב. זה לא אומר. שלא.
אמרתי את זה. כן כן. אוקיי.
איך זה צריך? לעבוד?
אוקיי. מה אתה מסתכל על זה של? מס הכנסה?
זה לא פשוט. אבל צריך לעשות סדר בין הציבור שלהם לבין שאלות.
ואני מצטערת על עצמכם, אתם עושים את זה לא ענייני, ככה הציבור יהיה בסדר.
כן, כאילו אני הולך, עושה לעצמי ולבן לבן הולך, שומע כל הקבצים לחלק אותם למקומות שונים וזה יוצא איזה שעתיים.
נוספות. זה נראה מדהים שכאשר יש בחירה אני מבין שאתה טוב בפנים.
אפשר לעשות? ילדים זה שמחה.
אוקיי, יש לנו פגישות. עם מומחים אחרים בתחום.
תסבירו לי האם ואיך זה?
ישפיע שהייתי אחד על החומר ואיזה מין סוג? של?
לא יודע כאילו זה מה שמזכיר. מאלה שמנסים לפתור מבחן ואז בודקים כל פעם אותם מושגים כמו שאני יושב במהלך כל היום.
לא יודע כלום. איזה כיף של בית ספר.
אני חושב. שזה. לא נראה ככה.
זה ממש לא נראה לי. זה בכלל קל. אוקיי, אז בחדר כמה פתקי בשאלה אחת ענקית.
אוקיי, שנייה, אבל אני לא עושה את זה. כי הצגתי את העניין הזה.
זה בסדר? וואו. זהו. הרסת אותי.
שאלה 2. RNA אתם שם מטריצות בסדר?
מה זה שלוש Crv? מה זה סיריוס?
בלק? זה לא. נכון?
בוא נראה מה זה טקס. מה זה בדיוק שילוב של?
אני איתך קצב שזה לא בהכרח התואר שביצעתי בשביל זה.
אם היית יכול לבחור אני יודע שאני זה שמה של הממשלה פרויקט הרבה שנים.
אבל יש היום מבחנים, לא ידע בכלל לקבוע את זה.
זה מה שאנחנו? כן? אני לא חשבתי באותו רגע שאני אקח אותי, אז אמרתי לך.
בהתחלה יצאו לי כאלה צמידים וניסיתי למרוח אותם, אבל זה כבר בסדר העדיפויות שלי.
יש יותר טוב מזה? לא, לא מדובר במנה חד משמעית.
אני מניח. נשמע כאילו זה פתוח.
אבל זה כאילו אבא זה רק ייסורים שלך ואני חייב לסיים את.
זה? אתה רוצה להחזיר?
את החברות שלך? אני לא מאשים Translation כרגע בכל הסיפור, אבל בוא ננתח את הזוגות שלנו פה ותראו מה הרלוונטיות של משפט המקור והרשע.
כל שיישאר ככה שהמילה היא זה המתאים על רקע פונקציה.
לא התייחסנו לזה קורס אינטרנטי עבור גיבוי של המילים בתרגום.
עד לפני כמה חודשים בדיקות דם ושתן כל דבר שאפשר לבקש אך היום זה בסדר.
בהתחלה? כן, אבל תפיסה חדשה.
זה יהיה בסדר. אוי, אני צריך להסתכל קצת על הנפרדים גדולים וכל מיני סוגים של שמחה ברחוב.
אחרי שאתה לומד את זה מספיק זה נחמד מאוד. אני מקווה שלא.
אין לך מושג. למה לא?
זה ממש לא יפה. עם כל הכבוד. באמת.
אני צריך לרשום את. הפוסטים.
שלך. עושה.
חסד עם עצמך. איך עושים זה לא סתם פה קוראים לזה היי או קוראים לזה אחד.
זה בסדר גמור, אבל זה ממש לא.
לפחות זה נחמד. המספרים שלך מראים באותו זמן.
שזה הגיוני. מערכת חברתית? פשוט עושה.
מאמץ לעבור על זה לסדר את זה. עירוני? חסר משהו? זה לשלוח להם נתונים של בן גוריון למצוא.
נניח פה ב 20 3 שניות ולפרסם. למרות שאתה לא מבין בעסקים אתה רואה את הנולד?
המון! הצלחה חתונה.
דיסטנס. דיסטנס?
אתה חושב שאתה רוצה לשמוע אותך במקום לחזור לשם משם?
להצביע שלך שם כל אשר יש להם עכשיו ויהיה.
יש תכנית לא ריאליסטית. כן אתה לא יודע מה השם של הבית.
שלך. אוקיי, אז אתה לא זוכרים.
מכל מה שדיברנו קודר וקודר. הזכרת שיש גם שאריות כמו דירוגים וביקורות.
אולי אפשר גם לעשות מזה סרט. סליחה.
טוב. אז הטרנספורטר המקורי היה Encounter disorder כפי שאתם מבינים.
ויועד למשימות למשל תרגום לאו דווקא כן, אבל מקרים שבהם ישנו איזשהו טקסט אחד קבוע וממנו אנחנו רוצים לייצר טקסט אחר.
מאז התפתחו גם עוד כמה גישות. אחת הגישות שדיברנו עליהן זה הגישה של Part כן או של Encounter Only Models, שבדרך כלל הרעיון שלהם הוא לייצר.
ולייצר בעצם עיבודים עבור מילים.
אבל בשונה ממה Skip גרם, הם בעצם מייצרים מה שנקרא קונטקסט עם Padding.
כן, עם Padding שתלויות שתלויים בשאר המילים במשפט.
אז איך זה נראה? אז Birth בעצם מבוסס על רעיון של פרי טריינינג, נכון שוב של הילרי Task.
במקרה שלנו זה מה שנקרא mask language modeling. כן, אז בגדול ברט בנוי ככה.
יש לו? כן.
אז יש לנו איזשהו משפט. בואו נגיד עכשיו נדבר על training.
Training או training. מה שאנחנו עושים זה בעצם לוקחים משפט.
כן לוקחים משפט ממסכים או חלקים ממנו. זאת אומרת מחליפים חלק במסך.
מחליפים חלק ב mask. זה ברנדון טו קנס.
מה שבעצם עמדנו מגדירים איזה שהם 15 אחוז מהמילים שעליהם אנחנו עושים שינוי.
אוקיי, ועכשיו אנחנו לוקחים את המילים האלה אחרי השינוי. כן, בוא נגיד.
ומכניסים אותם ל transformer deco Encounter.
כן, מהארכיטקטורה שראינו קודם. מקבלים וקטורים?
כן. מעניין.
אוקיי. ועכשיו מכל אחד מהם אנחנו בעצם עושים Coding ישירות.
איך נראה Coding פשוט production ו software as?
כן. כלומר אנחנו מכפילים אותם במטריצה. הם נמצאים באיזה שהוא RD.
כן מכפילים אותם באיזושהי מטריצה. כן, בדרך כלל זו אותה מטריצה שעשתה להם עם Padding גם פה, אז באיזושהי מטריצה ובעזרתה.
כן, אז איזושהי מטריצה שכשאנחנו מכפילים את נגיד אחד הוקטורים האלה, למשל VM.
ב. מה שאנחנו מקבלים זה בעצם score. זה בעצם מכפלות בגודל של אוצר המילים.
כן, אז בעצם זה מטריצה?
אז אני כופל אותה במטריצה הזאת. זה אומר שיש לי לכל מילה באוצר המילים פה איזשהו וקטור שאותו אני כופל מכפלה סקלר בית עם VM.
נכון? נגיד שמה שאני עכשיו רוצה להציג את זה VM כל אחד אחר שלו.
אני רוצה לעשות The code. אני מקבל score בגודל של אוצר המילים ואז אני עושה soft max ומקבל כן איזשהו וקטור, שכן הוא גם הוא.
עדיין אין הרבה מילים. עדיין בערבית, אבל הוא עכשיו כאמור כן חיובי.
מסתכל. אוקיי,
אז את הארכיטקטורה הבסיסית בעזרת זה מאמנים ספציפית מאמנים על ידי זה שלוקחים את
אותם 15 אחוז טוקנים שבחרנו באופן אקראי שחלק ניסחנו חלק החלפנו בתוכן אקראי,
חלק השארנו במקום ובעצם לגבי ה 15 אחוז מהתקנים האלה מחשבים Centro Plus בין הוקטור Output לבין הזהות האמיתית שלהם,
כלומר הזהות שלהם באיקס לפני שעשינו מיסוך וקלקול כן, ה Scorpion הזה עם ההחלפה האקראית וכן הלאה.
וככה מחשבים כוס האנתרופי וככה מאמינים. אוקיי, אז זה האימון?
אוקיי, שאלות עד כאן. ה 15 אחוז שבחרנו בהתחלה שאותה אנחנו משנים לאו דווקא משנים 90 אחוז מהם.
כן, ספרנו בזה. כן. אז זה כאילו כל Epoch.
אנחנו בוחנים את המשחקים מחדש של זה שזה קבוע בלמידה לאורך כל הזמן.
לא, זה לא קבוע. כן, כל פעם אתה בוחר אקראית. 15 אחוז מהם מגדיר את מה שאתה צריך.
כן כן, בדיוק. יפה.
אז זה האימון. בסוף האימון מה שיש לנו זה Encounter מאומן וכן עם Padding Meters.
פה וגם פה יש איזשהו Padding נכון כדי להכניס את זה לכאן.
בדרך כלל זה אותו double או נכנסנו לזה. הבעיה שלי זה position עם אינדקס.
כל הדברים הרגילים של transformer Income. אוקיי, מה עושים ב Insurance?
אז בדרך כלל אנחנו לא רוצים לעשות Insurance. למשימה הזאת כן, כי אובזילר היא לא נורא מעניינת.
כן. אז מה שאנחנו רוצים לעשות זה בעצם להשתמש בזה.
אתם יודעים מה? אולי אני קצת? או אולי אני קצת, אולי הגזמתי קצת?
ב 99 או 99 אחוז מהמקרים אנחנו לא רוצים להשתמש בזה ב במאה ה 18.
יש מקרים מאוד ספציפיים שבהם אנשים כן מתעניינים גם באימוץ מודל.
נגיד, למשל גבי סנדובסקי. אם אתם מכירים שהוא גם חבר סגל, כאן הם עבדו על פיענוח של לוחות חרס שכתובים באכדית וחלק מהאותיות נמחקו.
אז שם הם באמת רצו לעשות mask language Modeling. הם רצו למצוא מה היה במקום המיסוך או המחיקה, אבל זה לא המקרה הטיפוסי במקרה הטיפוסי.
מה שבעצם אנחנו רוצים לעשות זה להשתמש בה כדי לייצר לנו קונטקסט.
Police Wedding Weddings. אוקיי, אז מה הכוונה בקונטקסט police Wedding?
בעצם, התשובה לזה היא די פשוטה. כן. אז אם כל מה שאנחנו רוצים זה עם Weddings, כן, אנחנו לא רוצים לעשות fine tuning.
מה שאת כותבת מדבר עליו. אבל אם כל מה שאנחנו רוצים זה קונטקסט של אייזן בית דין.
מה שאנחנו עושים זה בהינתן משפט שאנחנו רוצים לייצג.
אוקיי, אנחנו פשוט מכניסים אותו.
מכניסים את המשפט הזה בלי קורה שם, כן, בלי כל ההחלפות וזה לתוך ה Encounter.
ומקבלים סדרה של וקטורים. ב RB.
אוקיי. למה שנרצה לעשות את זה לפעמים רוצים את זה. נגיד למשל, אם אתם רוצים לאנדקס אוסף של מסמכים.
כן, אתם רוצים איכשהו לאנדקס מילים או מסמכים או דברים כאלה.
אז לפעמים עושים את זה על בסיס כוס עם סמיילי פרטי, בין אם Padding של מילים רלוונטיות או ממוצע מילים או כל מיני דברים כאלה.
בסדר, אז לפעמים רוצים לעשות את זה. זה מה שנקרא קונטקסט עם Padding, אבל הרבה פעמים מה שאנחנו רוצים לעשות זה לבנות בית בהסתמך על ה another.
נכון לבנות איזושהי מערכת פרדיגמה חיה לאיזושהי משימה ספציפית שיש לנו עבורה training data.
נכון, ולזה קראנו fix it. אז מה ש fine tuning עושה fine Tuning הוא בעצם אימון נוסף.
הוא גם סוג של אימון שנקרא אחרי הטרי Training וה training שכתבנו שם, וכאן אנחנו מניחים שיש לנו עוד איזשהו אוסף של Labels.
נגיד למשל לייבל על המילים כמו Part of Speech Text או Labels על המשפטים כמו סנטימנט analysis או כל דבר אחר.
אוקיי, ועכשיו בעצם יש לנו איזשהו training data.
נכון, בעצם מין אוסף של. טקסטים או משפטים.
ואיזשהו לייבל שלהם. אולי זה לא נעים אל אחד, אולי זו סדרה של לייבל זקן.
אם זה לכל מילה, אז כבר לפי ההקשר. אוקיי.
אז זה אולי מילה לייבל בודד או סדרה של לייבל שמתאימה לעורך של המשפט, ומה שאנחנו עושים זה בעצם לוקחים את ה X.
כן, שוב לא עושים Correction או משהו כזה. מכניסים את זה לנקודה שעמנו.
שאותו אנחנו מתחילים מהתחלה לפי השלב הזה את הפרמטרים שלו כן, לפי הפרי טריינינג אז אתחול.
לפי אוקיי, מקבלים סדרה של וקטורים.
שמתאימה לתכנים של המשפט. כן, המתוקנים האלה עושים דה Coding בעצם בשלב בשלב האימון.
אז כן, אם זה נגיד זה לייבל של כל מילה בודדת, אז כל אחד מן הוקטורים האלה נכנס לאיזשהו מה שנקרא Classification Head,
שבדרך כלל זה איזשהו MVP קטן, אולי בשיכבה אחת או משהו כזה.
כן, אז אנחנו מכניסים אותם לאיזשהו Classification head זה נקרא כלומר רשת חדשה.
קטנה. אוקיי, שהוא פלט soft Marks על מרחב הלייבלים האפשריים.
כן, זה מרחב הלייבלים האפשריים הוא al. אז הוא פולט soft max.
One. בסדר. צ'אט כאן ועכשיו.
אפשר לאמן את זה עכשיו. למה קוראים לזה fine tuning? כי בעצם אנחנו לוקחים את הפרמטרים שאימנו פה פה.
ההנחה היא שיש לנו הרבה יותר Data. אוקיי, אז אפשר לעשות אימון של הרשת הזאת גם עם רשת די גדולה ועמוקה.
אפשר לעשות לה אימון אפקטיבי ואנחנו משתמשים בו כ איתחול לפרמטרים.
לשלב אימון נוסף שהוא יותר קטן כי הוא מסתמך רק על label data שההנחה היא שאין לנו ממנו המון.
אוקיי. בגלל זה ה MP הזה הוא קטן כי הוא מסתכל רנדומלית.
הסיגנל היחידי שיש לנו לאמן אותו זה אותה.
אין גדול. דוגמאות אימון. והעין קוטר עצמו יכול להכיל המון פרמטרים.
כי עיקר האימון שלו קורה בפרמטרים. זהו.
ואז אנו יכולים לעשות אינפורמציה בדרך הסטנדרטית. עכשיו זה למקרה שבו יש לייבל לכל מילה.
אם יש לייבל לכל המשפט או לכל הטקסט, מה עושים? אתם זוכרים את הנקודה הזו?
אז מה שעושים בדרך כלל זה מוסיפים עוד ספיישל Token כזה שבתחילת או לא משנה, בסוף אתה לא ממש משנה ה Document.
כן שפרי טריינינג זה סתם איזה Pad כזה.
כן, פשוט איזשהו Token קבוע שלא חלק מאוצר המילים הסטנדרטי ובעצם הווקטור שלו.
נגיד נקרא לו VF. כן, איזשהו פד כזה בהתחלה. מיוחד ומהותי.
0. עושים Coding ללייבל. אוקיי, אז בעצם מאמנים את Emp?
ומאמנים Emp שהוא הסתמך על.
על התוכן הזה, על התוכן של הפד שנמצא בהתחלה.
עכשיו אתם אומרים טוב, אולי קצת מוזר. מה אנחנו הולכים?
פד שאנחנו בכלל לא עושים איתו שום דבר בפרי טריינינג?
זה נראה קצת חבל, אבל בעצם אם חושבים על זה קצת זה לא.
זה לא כל כך נורא, כי בעצם בכל שכבה של ה Encoding הוא הרי עושה self attention על כל Token.
נכון? ובהנחה שכל ה Token הם כן הובנו להיות משהו מתקבל על הדעת,
אז כל התפקיד של בעצם של הפד הזה כן הוא סך הכל למצוא איזשהו שקלול בעצם של הקונטקסט של העסק עם Padding.
אוקיי, אז זה זה הרעיון. טוב, עכשיו שאלת על The code along.
לגמרי נכון. אוקיי, אז מה זה the code? אוקיי.
אז code הוא אנגלי? זה בעצם ה GPT לדורותיו.
הוא די code. ארון לימודים שמה שהוא אומר זה בעצם אפשר לעשות את זה כאן.
אז מה זה The only? Code דרום לי.
אין לנו משפט מקור וריח, אלא יש לנו רק רישא.
אוקיי, יכול להיות שהכניסו את משפט המקור, מה שעושים לפעמים כחלק מהרישום, כמו למשל אני רוצה לתרגם את המשפט הבא לגרמנית.
הלכתי הביתה בריצה. אז סגור מירכאות? כן, התרגום הוא נקודותיים, תשליל.
כן. אז בעצם הנקודה היא שיש לנו רק Stream אחד. כן, יש רק עוד מקום אחד שמקבלים ממנו.
אז זה רישא או אולי כן?
כן, אז קלט זה רישא. Y אחד עד Y הם.
פלט. כן, זה פשוט זה מה קורה כאן.
אז בעצם כל החלק הזה נמחק? זה מאוד מפשט את הארכיטקטורה.
גם cross extension אין טעם שיהיה יותר cross attention.
נכון הוא מה ששילב בין Decor Berlin Holder, בין עם Padding של Padding של Corner.
אז גם cross attention לא צריך. אז מה שיש לנו זה בעצם ה y.
נכנסים ל עם padding layer כמו שדיברנו קודם. שילוב של הנל ושל הוורדפרס עם Padding משם הם עושים mask attention.
Map חוזר חלילה כך וכך פעמים לוקחים את האיור m האחרון, מכניסים אותו,
מכפילים אותו באאוטפיט עם Padding Matrix ופולטים סופט ועושים מזה soft max וזה ההתפלגות הרגילה.
עכשיו היתרון הוא שזה ארכיטקטורה יותר פשוטה. החיסרון הוא.
בעצם. בעצם באיזו שהיא רמה, קצת אקשן או עליו את החיים.
כי אם קודם לכן הייתה לו גישה בכל שלב, בעצם הוא מודד את המשפט מקור באיזושהי דרך.
ועכשיו בכל שלב של ה Inferno בכל תחזית של המילה הבאה יש לו.
בעצם הוא יכול להסתכל על. יש לו בעצם גישה ישירה.
הוא עושה tension באופן ישיר על. על כל האינפוט של ה Embed.
זאת אומרת כל האינפוט של של ה source.
Sourcing. אז כן, כולם נמצאים לגמרי במעמד סימטרי. ברגע שאנחנו עושים master attention ולא self כמו שלהם.
אז בעצם לסדר יש חשיבות? כן, כי נכון, זה בדיוק מה שדיברנו על muscle attention כל פעם עם Padding נקבע רק על סמך מה שהתוכן הנוכחי ומה שקדם לו.
כן? אז מה שזה אומר זה. המשפט כן, אם נגיד יש לכם עכשיו משפט שאתם רוצים לתרגם והבנתם אותו ברישא, אז הייצוג של התוכן הראשון בו יסתמך רק על עצמו,
הייצוג של התוכן השני יסתמך על עצמו ועל מה שקדם לו והשלישי וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
בעוד שסל פטנט שאם אין לו את האילוץ הזה נכון, כל עם Padding יכול להיות כל קומבינציה קמורה עקרונית של כל התוכנית.
Source sentence. וכאן אנחנו כופים עליו כיווניות. אז נגיד לכאורה יכול להיות והאם זה קורה בפועל או לא?
אני לא יודע גם. סך הכל הרשתות כיום הן כל כך אקספרסיביות ויש להן כל כך הרבה דאטה.
ההנחה הרווחת היא שזה לא נורא משנה כן.
אבל עקרונית יכול להיות שאם נגיד אני אזמין את המשפט בסדר הפוך, אוקיי, ואני אגיד לו משהו כמו הנה משפט בסדר הפוך.
הנה משפט בעברית בסדר הפוך. Paste. כן, הטקסט תרגם אותו.
אולי גם בסדר הפוך כן או בסדר? ישר? לא יודע. כן, כל הדברים האלה עשויים לשנות כמובן.
כן. כי. בעוד שב Transformer in Order disorder מה שהסדר ב output כן שינה, אבל זה איכשהו בסדר, אנחנו איכשהו מקבלים את זה.
כן, גם שם יש ניסיונות לשכלל ולהכניס גם מה שנקרא Out of order Coding שהוא לא מייצר Token אחרי Token,
אבל לפחות ב Include אנחנו אומרים אין לנו בעיה, הכל לגמרי סימטרי.
כל ה Positions זה גם סימטרי וכן לא מאבדים את זה כאן.
אבל יש שאלה קצת בסיסית שאני צריך לשאול קודם על הנקודה לי שאתה עומד רישא או Y אחד, או אם אני מדמיין שזה כבר המילים הקודמות בתרגום.
אבל לפי הדוגמה שנתת זה נתת איזה משפט בגרמנית ואתה אומר תשלים לי אותו בעברית כאילו תתרגם לי אותו לעברית.
אז במובן נוסף, אפשר להגיד שזה דווקא כמו ה X1 על XML מקודם ופשוט אין לי y, אבל זה שרשור של שניהם.
נכון? כי עכשיו בדיקות הריון לי, הרי שאולי תהיה משהו כמו תרגם לגרמנית את I went home running.
ואז the translation is. נקודותיים איש?
ממש כן. וגם מההתחלה נכון. ואז תמשיך למילה הבאה וכן הלאה.
נכון, זה בעצם שרשור שלהם. לא שירשור של ה גם של Source.
צריך להגיע מאיפשהו נכון? כן המקום היחידי להכניס אותו בדיקות דאון לי זה כחלק מהרשת.
גם הזכר מונח אבל זה קשור למה שנקרא Instruction.
משחק models. כן כן אז להסביר את הנקודה הזאת.
כן. אוקיי, אז הרעיון באינטרנט Models בעצם language models.
במקור, כמו שאמרנו, זה פשוט מידות. הסתברות על מחשב Hoops זה פשוט מידות הסתברות על מחרוזות מאוצר המילים.
כן, זאת אומרת, זה בעצם בעיה שבה אנחנו רוצים לשערך את ההסתברויות.
בעצם נכון. איך אנחנו חושבים על זה? אנחנו חושבים על זה כאילו יש לנו משפטים בקורפוס.
הם נדגמו מאיזושהי התפלגות לא ידועה. כן איזשהו Distribution ואנחנו רוצים לשערך בצורה הטובה ביותר האפשרית את ההתפלגות הזאת נכון,
והתחלנו ממודל עם מרכיבים אחרי זה דברים שמבוססים על פיט פורוורד נטס, על הרעננים, על Transformers.
אבל בגדול הרעיון היה פשוט לשערך את ההתפלגות שממנה לכאורה נדגמו משפטים שעליהם התאמה ביצירת מודל.
זה לא הרעיון. כן, בעסק מודלס הרעיון הוא בעצם סוג של לקיים שיחה כן או או לענות על בקשות או על הוראות.
כן, אז וראינו שיש גם מקרים שבהם יש הבדל בין שני הדברים האלה.
נכון, יש הבדל בין ניסיון לשקף את המגוון לבין ניסיון בעצם לענות על ההוראות בצורה בצורה מיטבית.
אז אחד הדברים, למשל, כן, אחד הנקודות שלמשל כשרואים את זה זה אם יש שאלה עובדתית כן שאלה עובדתית ונגיד בקורפוס שלכם.
אוקיי, לקחתם איזשהו קורפוס? והשאלה העובדתית הזאת מה לעשות?
רוב האנשים יש להם מה שנקרא common concept. נכון, נתנו דוגמה כזאת.
רוב האנשים חושבים משהו מסוים, אבל ידוע ממחקר מדעי מבוסס מתוקף משוחזר שזאת לא התשובה הנכונה.
אין תשובה נכונה. היא אחרת. אוקיי, למודל שפה מהסוג הראשון שמשערים התפלגות מה הוא צריך לעשות?
להגיד את העקומות מסוג Caption בדיוק, או לפחות לייחס לה את ההסתברות היחסית שהיא מופיעה בקורפוס.
נכון, אולי לתת 90 אחוז. זה לא משנה כמה שכן לשערך, מהי ההסתברות שזה ומן הסתם לתת את רוב ההסתברות ל common Caption.
לעומת זאת, המודל השני שאמור להיות לא יודע Helpful Assistant או משהו כזה, זה לא בטוח שזה רעיון כל כך טוב שהוא יעשה את זה.
כן, כי כי ההנחה היא לפחות לרוב ה users. אני חושב ש.
כששואלים או נגיד כששואלים אותי שאלה אולי אני אציין שאת common לי believe משהו אחר, אבל בסוף אני אנסה לענות את התשובה הנכונה.
כן, אני לא פשוט אגיד את התשובה הנפוצה או הרווחת וזהו.
להסתפק בזה כאילו אוקיי. ואני גם לא אגיד את התשובה הזאת 90 אחוז מהזמן.
מה שאני אגיד כנראה תמיד זה את התשובה הנכונה.
או אולי אם אני קצת יותר ובוזי נגיד שיש גם תשובה לא נכונה ש.
שרבים חושבים שהיא נכונה. אוקיי, אז יש כאן הבדל גם במטרה, לא רק בטכניקה.
ובעצם המודלים החל מצאת GPT נגיד GPT 3 עוד היה מודל מהסוג ה density station.
כן שאני לא יודע אם זה באותו זמן לפני הצ'אט GPT.
הרי הטכנולוגיה בעצם שבבסיס צ'אט GPT במידה רבה כבר פותחה.
בטח שנה קודם ורובה כבר בעצם שנתיים קודם.
כן או יותר. זו הייתה קפיצת מדרגה טכנולוגית.
אבל זה היה רק מודל להשלמת משפטים כן או להתפלגות על משפטים.
רוב האנשים זה לא מה שהם רוצים. נכון? זאת אומרת, זה אמנם כלי מדרגה כאילו sleeping stone.
כאילו נכון מין. איך קוראים לזה בעברית? כן, זה נדבך שעל גביו אפשר לבנות הרבה דברים, אבל רוב האנשים לא רוצים שפשוט ישלימו.
ברוב ההקשרים נכון? הם רוצים. רוב השימושים כיום בצ'אט GPT מן הסתם או קלוד או Gemini.
הם לא להשלים בצורה המצטברת ביותר את המשפט שהתחלת נכון?
כאילו זאת לא התנהגות רצויה. אז בעצם הצ'אט GPT הוא ניסח מחדש את זה ככה שזה יהיה כלי שאני חושב שימושי הרבה יותר.
לפחות לרוב האנשים. כן. ועדיין השלמת משפטים היא רלוונטית במקרים מסוימים.
כן, היא נאמר, היא הדבר אולי נכון לעשות בדברים מסוימים.
נגיד, אם אתה מנסח מכתב נכון, יש את האוטו קומפלט, כזה שאמור לתת כן לא אמור לייצר תוכן כל כך חדש.
נכון, זה לא יותר טוב, זה לא יותר מדי טוב אם הוא כאילו פתאום ימציא איזה פגישה שאמורה לקרות מחר כאילו ויציע לך אותה נכון, גם אם זה משהו מאוד נפוץ,
אז אתה אומר בתוך התחום המאוד ספציפי של לכתוב כאילו כזה פורמלית IIS ופלח כזה של אימיילים רשמיים,
אז הוא מציע לך את האופציה הכי סבירה או כמה אופציות סבירות, נכון?
או נגיד למשל, אם נתתי את הדוגמה של Speech to טקסט כן נכון speech text אם אם אתה עכשיו מנסה לפענח את מה שאני אומר זה טוב.
אם תיקח מודל שמתייחס פחות או יותר פרופורציונלית. את כן, בוא נגיד שאתם עכשיו לא יודעים שום דבר עליי ועל הידע שלי.
אז אולי אם אתם עושים speech to טקסט, זה דווקא הגיוני להניח שאני יפלוט את common exception.
נכון, אולי כדאי לתת הסתברות יותר גבוהה פריורית ל common consumption מאשר לאמת הידועה רק ליודעי חן בודדים.
נכון? כי זה יעזור לכם הרבה יותר לתקן רעש. ככל הנראה אני רק בסיכוי של עשרה אחוזים אגיד את הדבר הנכון.
אם אני סתם בן אדם שמצאתם כאילו באופן אקראי, אז דווקא כדאי לכם שה prior שם ייצג את ההתפלגות באוכלוסייה ולא את האמת.
אבל ברוב ההקשרים שמשתמשים בהם כיום אתה תצטרך להגיד לו מפורשות צריך להגיד לו For the purpose of speech to text prior what is the most like או משהו כזה?
נכון? ואז אולי הוא יתן לך משהו בשאיפה. כן אם הוא עובד מספיק טוב, אבל אם סתם תשאל אותו מה האמינו המלומדים של ימי הביניים על צורה של כדור הארץ,
זה יהיה מוטעה מצידו לכתוב את התשובה הלא נכונה, גם אם היא רווחת.
כן. אוקיי, טוב, יופי, אז בסדר, נסיים טיפה לפני הזמן.
אולי באמת נעשה עוד שיעור חזרה לפני המבחן כשהרוב ככה תספיקו לעבור על מבחנים וכאלה.
אז אני אפרסם משהו. כן כן, אני אומר לא נראה לי באופן אבסולוטי הרוב בקורס כן כן, אז נראה לי הקורס רשומים איזה 200 או משהו ויש פה חמישה בערך.
כן טוב אחלה יופי.
אז תודה על ההשתתפות ועל ההתמדה. תודה רבה. תוצאות הפוכות.
מעולם. לא חשבתי שצריך להיות משהו כזה שיעשה.
תודה רבה רבה. תודה. ביי. אחד.